one-year anniversary of fierce
anti-government protests in Hong Kong
the city endured months of unrest as
some 1 million demonstrators filled the
streets to stop a controversial
extradition bill rallying to a cry of
liberate Hong Kong rainy Inocencio
reports one year ago this week more than
half a million Hong Kongers hit the
streets their anger targeted chief
executive Carrie Lam and a controversial
extradition bill their fear it would
give Beijing the power to disappear
people in Hong Kong into China's opaque
legal system CBS News was there when
police fired the first rubber bullets
and tear gas against angry demonstrators
we've just been tear-gassed by the
police you can see those bullets the
hitting of people that we were in a
group with the South protesters shoved
an umbrella in my hand a helmet on my
head and washed the burning chemicals
from my face
protestors stormed the legislature on
the symbolic date of July 1st the 22nd
anniversary of the day the UK handed its
former British colony back to China Hong
Kong's summer of discontent devolved
even more a vicious gang attack on
demonstrators in a subway police
brutalizing protesters clashes that shut
down Hong Kong's
Airport with tension made even worse
after police shot a teenager at
point-blank range demonstrations still
raged with police laying siege to
protesters barricaded in a university
right in front of me are hundreds of
Molotov cocktails here the smell of the
flammable material is very much in your
face
but this year Beijing is playing a
heavier hand passing a new national
security law to clamp down on Hong Kong
while that city arrested pro-democracy
leaders how does this realistically end
I hope this will end with free elections
that's our dream and I will role and
responsibility is to turn our dream from
impossible to be possible yet even this
weekend on the one-year anniversary of
major protests Hong Kong where's Val
this is still only the beginning
for CBS this morning Saturday rainy
innocencio Tokyo